[Music]
the race for a vaccine
the rollout of mass inoculation programs
the world's never seen so many funds
flow into the prevention of a disease
but while everyone's focused on vaccines
what about a cure
or treatment for those infected or those
of us who could still catch the
coronavirus
especially as a second or third wave
crests in many countries
we need a three-month lockdown not three
weeks there's no other treatment and
we'll still have problems
meanwhile tens of millions of people
around the world are still fighting for
their lives
hospitals only have a small arsenal of
treatments against covert 19
and health authorities have their
reservations about some of them
the other catch is that all of the
treatments have to be given early in the
course of the disease
otherwise they can be counterproductive
seriously ill covert 19 patients can
expect to get much more effective
treatment nowadays
doctors are no longer fighting an
unknown cunning entity as they were in
the initial stages of the pandemic
they know much more about the
coronavirus its effects
and the medication which can help in an
emergency
for one we know that it all depends on
proactive treatment of symptoms
consistently reducing fever pain relief
antibiotics if needed
additional oxygen and if necessary
prompt ventilation
and we also have two treatment
strategies now which target the disease
more accurately
indeed
doctors treating serious cases of covet
19 now rely primarily on those
medications
rem desevere is used to restrict viral
reproduction
but it needs to be administered in the
early stages of treatment
however a recent study by the world
health organization caused the stir
when it said remdessevier only has a
minimal or even no
influence on mortality or the length of
hospital stays
covert 19 specialists at hanover's
university hospital
say they've had different results with
it
we have high quality studies which show
rem desevier has a measurable effect on
the course of the disease
especially if administered promptly and
the patient is not seriously ill
that's the window of opportunity with
badly ill patients like those in
intensive care who've been symptomatic
for longer
then rem deserve probably
doctors have also discovered that
administering cortisone to severely ill
covet 19 patients can be quite effective
we now know the coronavirus provokes
life-threatening immune system reactions
involving drastic inflammation of organs
and blood vessels
cortisone reduces swelling and that can
save lives
especially of those patients who need
ventilating
the complexity of the disease makes
finding a targeted therapy a serious
challenge
in later stages patients are at risk of
developing issues
such as thrombosis in their lungs and
organs some patients can suffer
long-term effects
while great progress has been made on
finding a vaccine for covet 19
the wait for a cure continues
implorex is a biopharmaceuticals company
that develops treatments
ceo niels riedemann joins us so
scientists have found several vaccines
all in record time but
where does that leave people like you
doctors and researchers who are looking
for treatments
yeah first of all thanks for having me
on the show much appreciated um
yeah treatments um are different animals
so to speak and i think they are
clearly important um with respect to
covet 19 you know the
a lot of people don't i'm not really
aware that this
this disease has many different facets
and many different faces
yes there's the healthy population that
needs to be protected vaccines are
of utmost importance and then there's
those that get sick
and get well soon and then there's those
that get very sick and they need
treatment
and they may have problems and even die
and as we know that's that's why we are
all afraid
about this disease and i think
treatments are important there are
companies like ours that have studied
and worked in the field of viral
inflammation
and viral sepsis for many many years
trying to prevent
our immune response causing damage to to
tissues and organs
and leading to multi-organ failure and
death and so
i think if this works and if we if we
can make an impact of course that's a
great news for the people that are
greatly affected and that are really
severely critically ill
but it also is i think a great great
thing to have
for new pandemics or for mutating
viruses because
immune response patterns they are very
similar between viruses
and uh if we were to be successful with
the treatment that could be a great
protection also in the long run
just how effectively can drugs and
therapies help sufferers cope with
covert 19
we do believe they can i mean this the
the bar is relatively high you need to
show it in well-controlled clinical
studies
so you can't just have good early
results and say i'm going to run
for an authorization approval you have
to really statistically plan a trial
treat enough patients and prove that
your drug can in our case try to prevent
mortality prevent death or in other
cases prevent that patients get
more severely sick get intubated get
dependent on life
and organ support so we believe that
there are drugs in the early stages of
the disease that may
prevent the virus causing the strong
immune response and causing
through replication and then there are
drugs like ours that when you have a
strong immune response trying to
modulate that response and trying to
prevent that your immune system causes
damage to your own organs
so we have seen interesting early stage
phase two data
that point to a potential mechanism
we've published this
in the lancet rheumatology and we
believe we can help patients that's why
we went to phase three and
uh we're eager to see data this year but
mr
friedman you then need the funds don't
you to um
to to produce these drugs and uh
that funding gap seems to be quite big
between what's going into vaccines and
what's going into treatments like yours
yeah it's uh thank you for bringing that
up and we as you know we've
we founded an initiative in germany
called beat cough and i i know a lot of
my colleagues have the same topic we've
seen phenomenal and great fast funding
for vaccines
and in fact in europe and specifically
in germany we have not seen targeted
funding for the late stage projects that
would be equivalent to vaccines so while
there were very early programs for
pre-clinical research which won't see
the patient in in the years to come
and now there's first programs for early
stage clinical research that
is of course size wise a multiple lower
with 40 50 million
all together for multiple tasks we need
a funding that is equivalent and that is
is a real funding for late stage
projects meaning that you can produce
uh material for the market for the
patients fast
that you can prepare for the market and
that you can run the expensive phase 3
studies
this is largely completely lacking here
and that's why we found it beat cough we
really want to make
create awareness that this may be of
utmost importance
also in the midterm as we may have um
therapeutics available um already during
this year
and then we want to get them to the
patient very briefly tell me more about
your drug and if it will actually get to
the market
well i'm a ceo of a public company i'm
not supposed to make uh
forward-looking statements predicting
the future uh i
i talked a little bit about our
conviction about the mechanism that we
are after and that we are
the the founders of this company i'm one
of them we're 20 years
in this type of research so we do
believe there's a chance that we can
make it to the market otherwise we would
have not started phase three
and you know it's a similar thing with
the vaccines there's always a risk that
it doesn't work long term there's always
a risk that's not but
but we've taken the risk and we've seen
phenomenal responses
first ones here with the german company
by on tech together with pfizer
uh then moderna in the us so so
why not also invest in therapeutics i
mean if we have
progress there it will make a whole lot
of difference
for affected patients and potentially
also for future pandemics that's why i'm
really advocating to put more funds
to help therapeutics new therapeutics
targeted therapeutics to
also make it into the clinic infrared
ceo neil sriderman thank you very much
thank you very much for having me time
for your questions on the coronavirus
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
should the drug ivermectin be used to
treat covid19 patients
this medication has been widely used in
some parts of the world
especially south america as a treatment
for covet 19
despite the fact that that evidence that
it works
is still not convincing the bolivian
government
actually authorized it as a therapy back
in may
after a very theoretical and
controversial study in april
indicated that ivermectin might help
against sars cove too the compound
which is made by microorganisms that
break down
organic matter in the soil
is a powerful tool in our
pharmacological toolbox
for getting rid of a wide range of nasty
parasites among them head lice
and intestinal pin worms um in fact
the researchers who discovered the class
of substances it belongs to
won the nobel prize for their work a few
years ago
there are dozens of ongoing trials
looking at whether
or not ivermectin could also be used to
treat
covid19 but so far none of them have
provided the kind of
clear-cut evidence that national or
international
health authorities would require to
recommend it
um published studies are at odds
with some showing no benefits or or or
even the covet 19 patients who took the
anti-parasitic drug got worse
while others reported improvements or or
positive results like lower mortality
rates in patients that took it
the thing is for basically all of the
studies published so far
experts have complained about flaws
in methodologies so at the moment
at least i would continue to ignore any
sensationalist
online claims that ivormectin can
cure or help cure covid19
and wait for more data from larger scale
trials to come in um pretty much
all authorities are still issuing
warnings not to take the compound
for anything except what it's meant for
to treat an infestation with parasites
and and also to stick to the prescribed
doses
for that um if their advice changes i'll
let you know here
and just briefly officials are deploying
dogs to sniff out covert infections in
some schools in italy
the company that trains them says it was
able to get their canine companions up
to speed in a few weeks
hundreds of students and teachers at
this high school handed over masks for
testing
the dogs managed to signal five out of
260 tests